joining us now for some analysis is
retired advice Marshall Sean Bell um
Sean let's talk about these cluster
Munitions why are they so controversial
yeah they've been around for a long time
and these gray hairs are testimony to
the fact that they used to be a central
pillar of our military capability they
weren't controversial at all
um but that was the time before we had
Precision weapons that could actually
seek out and strike targets accurately
so in the day the only way to hit
targets particularly mobile targets like
tanks was have an area weapon where you
looked uh fired lots and lots of
bomblets around it some would hit some
would miss the challenge with those
weapons though is that not and I've seen
one of them here
um is that there's a lot of ordinance
inside but not all of little bomblets go
off when they hit the ground and that
leaves some unexploded ordinance around
uh up to 10 in fact more than that for
some of the Russian weapons now the
challenge though those bomblets are
unexploded bombs they stay in the ground
for literally decades and the biggest
casualties from these weapons over 98 is
actually civilian casualties after the
event and over half of those are
children as a result of that now that
we've got Precision weapons over 120
Nations have actually banned the use of
these including the UK but Russia
America and Ukraine are not signatories
to that agreement it's interesting you
say that now we have Precision weapons
we're not using them what was the reason
that we decided not to use them was it
that we have Precision weapons or was it
that they're so dangerous that 98 of the
casualties from these are from civilians
like a lot of these things it's not a
binary Choice
um over the years the West has invested
a huge amount of money in Precision
weapons and that's been the asymmetric
advantage that we've been applying to
Ukraine is giving Precision weapons so
it means that big bombs you can actually
have them much smaller because if you're
going to hit the target you can tailor
the effect and you don't have all the
collateral damage back in the day we had
no no way of doing that and therefore
the only way to guarantee striking
targets was a football pitch size of
bomblets and you could guarantee to be
on the line of a tank you wouldn't be
able to hit it directly on but you would
guarantee with a whole lot of omelets
not in not in war but certainly we've
used them on training ranges and they're
remark to be effective at hitting tanks
particularly they were at the in the
Cold War they were a central pillar of
the Harrier forces weapon and we we used
to a plan to be using them all the time
so overnight they didn't suddenly become
Dreadful weapons I mean there is an
argument that says any weapon is
Dreadful
um but actually if you compare the dud
rates the amounts of ordinance that gets
left unexploded mines create 10 times
more deaths annually around the world
than these do doesn't mean they're not
dangerous but I think the context is the
American weapons are significantly more
effective
um the Americans have been arguing
there's a 2.35 dud rate I think that
still sounds a lot but if you look at
some of the Russian weapons that have
been used in uh Ukraine at the moment
they're up to 40 percent so nitri nearly
half the bomblets don't go off so they
leave a Carnage around but any dud rate
is going to leave a legacy the point
being is that if Ukraine is going to use
them they're going to use them on their
own soil so they own that risk and if
they use them on minefields trying to
clear big trunches of minefields after
the war they're going to have to clear
all these mines anyway so clearing the
ground or unexploded ordinance as well
as the mines can be done together and
just finally the Russians have been
using these in harkev for example the
ukrainians the UN says they have they
say they haven't but when you're when
you're in the middle of a battle and
you're looking at what to deploy where
when you look at cluster Munitions
what's happening in Ukraine where do you
think that they would use them and why
are they saying yes if you're going to
send these please on behalf of Ukraine
and the US saying we're going to send
you these yeah one of the challenges I
think is we often commentating on this
through the peacetime environment must
remember that president zlinski is
fighting a war of national survival here
and he you know he cannot afford to lose
he's running short of weapons and one of
the challenges he's got on the spring
offensive is his facing established
Russian trench systems and a huge
Minefield he could use his troops his
infantry to gradually take take those
out be highly costly highly nutritional
and also take time if you use something
like a cluster weapon it could blow a
path through the Minefield if you use
enough of these things and therefore
allow his tanks and heavy weapons to get
through and potentially create a
breakthrough and bring the war to a much
earlier end and that is why I think this
very controversial issue but frankly
president zlensky has got a choice
between making progress loads of people
are dying this war anyway moving it on
and getting on the offense but he owns
the risk of these Legacy unexploded
bombs so it's no great surprise that
he's been asking these weapons and
ultimately President Biden was reluctant
initially it's been a difficult decision
but he has ultimately decided to go with
him okay Sean thank you so much